the sun is releasing massive spurts of
energy that are headed directly toward
Earth and if they hit us it could change
everything power grids could be wiped
out our Communications could cease to
exist Humanity might be put back into
the Stone Age all because of a solar
storm but what makes them so
powerful how is it possible for
something like this to happen in
2024 and why are they so
dangerous this is what if and here's
what would happen if a solar storm hit
Earth in
2024 so how could something like this
happen anyway well it all starts with
the cycle of our sun known as the solar
cycle this is an 11year stretch in which
the sun's solar activity
increases and decreases
the cycle starts with just a few
sunspots raging about and creating mass
amounts of energy and then five or 6
years later it reaches its peak with
anywhere from 100 to 200
sunspots then it ramps back down for the
last 5 years and we start another solar
cycle currently we're in our 25th cycle
since we began tracking the sun in
1755 and unfortunately for us scientists
predict that the sun spots will peak in
2024 this means there's a higher chance
that a solar storm will occur now before
we get to our solar storm what are
sunspots anyway well they're cooler and
darker areas of the Sun that are created
by a strong magnetic field they're not
directly responsible for creating solar
flares but it just so happens that
flares are most common in these sunspots
due to their High magnetic activity the
magnetic field lines can become twisted
and Tangled near certain parts of the
Sun and they can suddenly snap and
realign which creates a massive burst of
energy this can result in a solar storm
so now that the sun has released this
massive amount of energy what will
happen to you on Earth well when a solar
storm occurs you won't notice it right
away that's because it takes a few
minutes before it reaches Earth hurry up
and get in your last couple of YouTube
videos because once this storm hits
Everything
Changes now the first thing you might
notice is that more and more auroras
will start popping up worldwide this
typically happens when charged particles
from the solar storm interact with the
Earth's atmosphere although these sights
in the sky look beautiful the good parts
about a solar flare end there
due to the effect on our geomagnetic
field most of our technology would stop
working things like satellites GPS and
radio Transmissions would become
incredibly spotty your cell phone likely
wouldn't be able to pick up any signal
and Communications worldwide would start
to fade out or become less
reliable but that would only be if we
were affected by a few solar flares this
is an entire solar storm where talking
about here these are comprised of
multiple attacks by the sun on the Earth
but before we get to that people on
Earth aren't the only ones affected by
this astronauts up in space would also
suffer the
consequences their situation could be a
lot worse the sun would be blasting them
with intense solar radiation and if
they're not in a specially shielded area
on the spaceship a solar storm could
prove deadly they could get radiation
sickness as well as develop cancer later
on the solar storm could also destroy
their ability to communicate with their
mission control and vice
versa this is just what would happen on
the first day of the solar storm but
several days later as you're still
having trouble getting cell reception
another massive attack would come from
the Sun a phenomenon known as a coronal
mass ejection or CME for short would be
coming right for Earth you know voicing
all these videos and checking all the
scripts for these episodes I end up
sitting around a lot and I'm not as
active as I'd like to be but that all
changed with the sponsor of today's
video co-pilot you know I don't know if
you can tell I've never really worked
out before I don't know what it was
maybe it was the new year but co-pilot
was the exact motivation I needed a real
trainer to keep me honest they're great
they set me up with a trainer Josh is my
guy shout out Josh you can text and call
your trainer regularly and they build
you various workouts I started with just
three a week but I hope someday to go to
Five if I can Josh checks in with me
every day to make sure I've done my
workout and that I'm feeling good the
other good thing I like about it is is
that I can do it at home I can do it at
the gym too but I don't have a gym
membership so Josh and I talked about
what kind of equipment I have at the
house two dumbbells and he built me the
workouts around that I like that I never
have to think about what kind of
exercises I should be doing everything
is planned for me by my coach now if you
want to make Fitness a bigger part of
your life well give co-pilot a try check
the link in the description and get 14
days of free personalized
Fitness a CME is a massive explosion of
plasma and electromagnetic radiation
from the Sun this mass ejection can
cause violent geomagnetic storms that
interfere with Earth's magnetic field if
this were to happen Earth as we know it
could change for good
just look at what happened in
1859 a solar storm known as the
Carrington event occurred it disrupted
and Flatout destroyed Telegraph
Communications luckily in this case
Earth was able to recover relatively
quickly from what today would be a
cataclysmic event Telegraph
Communications were a simple technology
Telegraph lines could be repaired
quickly and things went back to normal
but what would happen today
our lives are so much more reliant on
technology and we have so much more of
it this time the tech interruptions
wouldn't just stop with the odd glitch
or spotty signal instead a solar storm
could be so bad that it would make all
technology stop working yeah the intense
levels of electromagnetic radiation
could wipe out entire power grids and
communication systems even something as
simple as buying groceries with your
credit card would be
impossible we're talking about a full-on
global
blackout if you were in an airplane the
cockpit could lose communication with
air traffic control and not know where
to go or with the intense radiation
levels hitting Earth the plane could
fall entirely the same goes for Subways
and trains they could come to a complete
stop in their tracks this would cause
catastrophes all around the world planes
falling from the SK die trains
crashing now not having power at your
house would be the least of the world's
worries because entire cities including
all hospitals would be without power no
power means it's harder or impossible to
treat certain patients the lack of power
and Technology malfunctions could cause
millions of people to Die the solar
flares and CMEs might last anywhere from
a couple of hours to a few days but
that doesn't mean this event would be
over just yet because of all the damage
to our power grids Communications and
Technology Earth would take some time to
recover it might be weeks or months
before we get back to normal we'd have
to rebuild parts of our power grids and
communication systems and depending on
the parts needed well this might take
another several
weeks and take into account the lack of
communication that the world would
suffer I mean talking to your neighbors
is one thing but how would you
communicate with another city or country
Global Supply Chains would collapse this
would delay things even further but once
Humanity got all these things sorted we
would
rebuild what once felt like the end of
humanity might turn into a simple
footnote in Earth's history the result
of a solar storm could be traumatic and
life-changing but humans would live to
see another day so How likely is
something like this well it's tough to
predict we can look at the solar cycles
and see how many solar flares occur but
there's no telling if they'll hit Earth
or not and although a solar storm Could
Happen well keep in mind that even
though we're more reliant on technology
than ever before our technology is also
more resistant communication technology
and power grids are built to withstand
various types of interference
NASA is also working on technology to
help predict and warn us about solar
flares if one is headed our way well
here's what you can do to prepare Keep A
well-stocked emergency and first aid kit
nearby like with any natural disaster
it's important to be equipped with first
aid equipment non- perishable food and
water you might want to invest in surge
protectors and remember to unplug any
Electronics if a solar storm occurs
lastly look into off-grid power supplies
backup energy sources like generators or
solar
panels then just wait it out the world
should return to
normal but what if it never
did what if Earth experienced some of
the craziest world-ending scenarios
ever well that sounds like a story for
another what if remember that if you
want to make Fitness a bigger part of
your life then give co-pilot a try click
the link in the description to get 14
days of free personalized
[Music]
Fitness